dude let's Rob these guys let's get them
let's get these guys I feel like there
should be like some sort of like f word
a lot in court what's the f word yeah uh
yeah like so my like like
[Music]
did you guys know that movie fans can
now Sue over misleading trailers who are
they suing the person that makes a
trailer or the movie itself partially
dumb as [__] but where's this going did
you guys watch the movie called
yesterday
James Bond those Ana one armas yeah oh
that one okay from the two girls one cup
thing all right no she so she did well
later right no
um Resurgence
we're ruining the whole like [__] you
guys okay no so so
um they're fans of our Anna De armas and
there's a movie called yesterday
which stars Hamish Patel and like it's a
movie about how a guy wakes up in a
world where he's like hey uh anybody
heard of The Beatles And everyone's like
what the [__] is the Beatles and then he
just does their music the premise is
amazing really good really good friends
really good premises oh really so then
in the trailer for this movie she was
like his love his alternative love
interest he has a primary love interest
but then she was like the alternative
low mattress but then they did testing
for the movie as they do always and they
were like yeah we don't want to detract
from like the main love story because
the audiences hate that he went with
another chick eventually because like
they love the original love story so
we're just gonna ax it we're gonna pull
it all out but in the trailer on a day
armis is in there so these two [__]
[__]
they rent a movie for 3.99 they like
split it
losers right they rent us what they like
split up pieces of [__] pieces of [__]
come back and they did it through like
red box they did it through Redbox three
I'm talking 3.99
DVDs are always scratched up too exactly
they're all [__] up they never work I
will you know why I think because of
conspiracy I think Netflix hires people
just to [__] score that [__] they pay
time to play Tic-Tac-Toe on the back and
then put it back just put a bunch of
cats in the machine it's because heads
do red box and chill and then they just
they do lines on the on the movies
um
they rent the movie and then they're
like what the [__] there's no MD armas
so what are we gonna do and so they're
like well let's [__] Sue because of
emotional damages and [__] what stuff
not emotional damages
misrepresentation and false advertising
they claimed that she was in the movie
through a trailer and it's not the case
and how many [__] movie trailers have
we all watched where you see something
some scene that doesn't exist in those
oh yeah tons all the time because they
made the trailer before the movie's done
but now all these big movie studios have
to [__] themselves because like oh no
what if we false represent our audiences
and they can sue us because they won how
much oh my so this sets the president
pisses me off [__] that judge dude I
thought there was gonna be way more sex
which judge rule them that favor so they
they sued for five million dollars what
Mill yeah
and they want I don't know how much they
got
what do we do to I what what's the
quantification of like what's the five
mil what is the fight I need this yeah
five mil of heartbreak oh my god well
they're saying false advertising and
they won 2023 we need to scratch this
entire business model find the right
lawyer who's just as much a scumbag as
us and just start suing [__] let's get
in a lawsuit we're gonna I don't make a
business off of leeching on others oh we
should though well then you don't have
to be a part of it we should do this in
2023. we gotta find our next and I'll
sue you for excluding him
for making me feel bad oh I'll win that
[__] lawsuit every day then what's
the five mil represents isn't that wild
I gotta let Anthony do the work Jesus
gets the money and I sue him and then
that's I don't have to work as hard
that's good can we all Sue Anthony yeah
I could understand if if they were like
okay we'll give these two dudes their
money back and then they had to pay like
fines to whatever MPAA or some [__] but
like what the heck is five mil to two
guys that watched a movie so the
district judged is it a class action
Stephen Wilson is in order rejecting
Universal's attempt to dismiss the case
insisting that false advertising claims
only stand when a significant portion of
reasonable consumers could be deceived
but he determined that Universal is
correct that shows involves some
creativity and editorial discretion
however this does not outweigh the
commercial nature of a trailer at its
core a trailer is an advertisement
designed to sell a movie but providing
consumers with a preview of the movie so
they use that then disclose how much was
one because they suited for five million
I don't know how much
don't they it could have been four
dollars in trailers don't they have the
uh like a disclaimer at the end like
this is this may be modified from their
original you know yeah and like the
scenes could be whatever I think that's
before a movie brother oh well shouldn't
that [__] suffice for what the oh
you're I know what you're saying you're
saying like yeah really parent the guys
blah blah and it's like this has been
mortified the food you're screaming and
perfect oh is that what you're thinking
modify it's format I feel like this film
is not yet been rated or like modified
from the original I don't think it's
like yo like this is a representation of
our film I could I could see that having
something as major as Anna to armist not
in the real that's a big difference yeah
yeah that's like being a wonder fan yeah
if you're a
Wonder Woman trailer and then like she
had a [__] wardrobe mishap and then
her corset fell down and you're like
dude I was expecting titties dude in the
trailer there was there was titties yeah
dude it's in the trailer there were
titties honestly in the red band trailer
it's like it's like a bunch of Steve
heads right Steve Green fans who go
what's funny who they're called stupid
yeah yeah they go to see the movie
called The Wedding ringer
which you know I was in the trailer for
and then they they cut yourself I've
been cut from the film I wasn't I've
been in the film
um but imagine like the horror and like
that check the IMDb imagine
psychologically like what's going on
with these people well you guys can't
relate you've never been in these things
but I have and so like in like my old
buddy Kev Hart like old Kev like he
would he would have my back right now
he'd be like oh my God I'm gonna Sue
Dante Bosco because I thought Joe was
gonna be in way more of a fabulous
Filipino cheers but I'm gonna assume
because he didn't put me on more but I'm
also gonna assume that there's no way
[__] Universal or whatever gave these
guys five million dollars they had to at
least go to a settlement of like 50
Grand I don't know or something you know
what I mean like come on even even a
settlement when they spent only four
dollars to rent a Red Box movie and
split it I'm gonna Sue Dante Bosco
because I thought I was gonna watch a
movie where judge's cow was playing
Michael Jackson and he wasn't
Michael's that offended me yeah I was
also offended that Joe apparently was
Vietnamese in that movie right I did a
better accent than you can no it was
actually a really bad Vietnamese accent
I had a Vietnamese color what is the
automatic counter attack it was a really
bad Vietnamese accident it was so
excited was it bad no I had a Vietnamese
coach there well then I'm gonna sue your
coach Vietnamese cultural coach dude
let's Rob these guys let's get them
let's get these guys I feel like there
should be like some sort of like f word
a lot in court what's the f word [__]
yeah uh yeah like somebody like like
flashy oh yeah yeah and then they could
just be like any time that it reaches
the corner like get these two flashers
out of here yeah that's really good
flashy guy because like what the [__]
like you paid three bucks 3.99 for the
and they're soon for five million that's
just being a flash that doesn't but this
is probably the last time this is ever
gonna go no this is a precedent bro do
you know what a president everything
else is gonna [__] it starts like
this or maybe it's just a disclaimer
because of the two [__] stupid ass
flashers we now have to look yeah hey do
you guys look I might Sue I'm not gonna
lie I might Sue not a joke if you guys
remember Sam Ravi Spider-Man 2001 there
was a trailer and it came out Bard knows
this Spider-Man's is stomping a diamond
Heist
there's a helicopter that's flying
through New York City and all of a
sudden the helicopter stops moving and
you look up and between the two towers
there's a helicopter spun up in a
spider's oh wow but guess what
[__] I never saw that [__] in
the movie and I want my [__] money
you pieces of [__] cut that scene yeah
wow you know why they cut it why Twin
Towers right because the Twin Towers
weren't there anymore oh my gosh
well it's funny nothing I'm ready to get
my [__] money I was damaged by that I
went to see this movie and I was so
excited about that scene I was like I
had boners and all kinds of excitement I
was 13. the whole the whole time all the
things that you're excited about when
you're through they think they stole
your childhood that's a lot of them
brought me in my job do you think also
people sued the New York tourism Bureau
that year
laughs
if we're double it down they must hate
money
it's a whole cash grass we're both going
down on this [__]
[Music]